if I do my job in the next few minutes
I'm going to give you the secret of
happiness so that when you go home
tonight you can start living a happier
life and you can start sharing with more
people so that they can have a happier
life too
so let's start with what we know about
happiness there have been hundreds
literally hundreds of studies by
economists and social scientists and
psychologists about happiness hundreds
over the past thirty and forty years and
basically they all start by asking the
question who is happy in the United
States we know that all the way back to
the 1970s a very stable proportion of
the population is very happy about a
third of Americans say anonymously and
in accurate tests and an accurate
surveys that they're very happy people
okay we have no reason to doubt that
this is true a little over fifty percent
say they're somewhat happy and about ten
to fifteen percent of the population is
chronically depressed and say they're
not very happy okay now that's actually
not the most interesting question the
most interesting question is what brings
happiness and we know the answer to that
too it's three things three things bring
happiness genetics big life events and
choices and I'm going to tell you about
all three starting with genetics now a
few years ago social scientists at the
University of Minnesota constructed a
wonderful database that included 75
pairs of identical twins born between
the mid 1930s in the mid 1950s now they
were separated at birth and adopted to
separate families it's like a social
scientists dream it's almost as if the
government had done this
and at age 40 that were reunited and
they were given a personality test so
they were asked about the things that
we're going on their lives in the way
that they viewed their lives this is
really interesting because you've got
DNA carbon copies of each other and they
have different upbringing so you can net
out the parts that are nature in the
parts that are nurture statistically
what do they find
they found that 48% of their happiness
is genetic as a matter of fact they
found that more of their personality was
genic than they ever understood before
40% of how you vote is genetic 40% of
how you worship is genetic so this
explains some things if you have
somebody in your life who's chronically
happy you have a co-worker who's happy
all the time it's very irritating by the
way and so sometimes you wonder you know
that person is just happy all the time
what are they doing right what's your
secret
the secret is their DNA are you a grumpy
person are you dark and brooding it's
your DNA it's not your fault you have
lousy parents it's basically what comes
down to so if that's the case does it
really matter what we do the answer is
yeah because if half of it is taken away
from you you better get the other half
right now 48 percent is genetic but
there are other innate qualities other
innate characteristics that are really
important the most interesting of which
is gender who's happier men or women
the answer is women most studies the
overwhelming majority of studies find
that women are happier than men and
always have been okay I mean that's too
bad guys but I've studied this myself
and I find the scent found the same
thing I've looked at the happiness of
men and women by marital status okay and
what you find married women are happier
than married men single women are
happier than single men widowed women
are way happier than widowed men
what's so funny about that is I told
that one to my wife and she says huh no
kidding yeah in general women are
happier than men here's another
interesting mystery what's the average
unhappiest age in a man's life I had
heard about this phenomenon forever so
of you I mean this is the male midlife
crisis right when you think it is
seventy seventeen that doesn't count
only grownups forty-five 45 it's 45
that's exactly right 45 is the average
unhappiest asian a man's life and it
goes something like this the trajectory
of life for men is interesting and
sometimes a little sad see when you're
in your 20s and 30s the life recipe is
actually kind of simple its life is like
a superhighway when you're in your 20s
and 30s if you want to get ahead and you
wanna have a better life and you want to
be happier and more successful just hit
the gas
just look for more money and look for a
better career and look for more
promotions and it's simple the problem
is on the superhighway guys get to age
45 and a bunch of them stop and they say
I think I'm on the wrong road I don't
want to be on the superhighway but I
can't stop because I've got the house
payment and I've got all this stuff it's
hard I get hit I'll get an accident if I
stop it'll be bad if I stop there's what
a lot of guys fine yet now okay next
question what do they want staying on
the same metaphor what they want is to
be on another road that they picked
themselves they want to be on a little
dirt road with a motorcycle on it where
the drivers not wearing a helmet that's
what they want so who's the guy on the
motorcycle because the secret to
happiness is being the guy on the
motorcycle without the helmet so I don't
know who he is
tell me about him I know who he is he's
me and I'll tell you how it works when I
was 19 I dropped out of college
dropped out kicked out splitting hairs
and I ran off to play music for a living
I was a French horn player that's all I
wanted to do I wound up in the Barcelona
Symphony and by my late 20s it was great
I loved the music I still love the music
it's the best music ever written it
seems like a dream right but I got a
glimpse of my 45 year old self I got a
look in the crystal ball it was all the
guys working with me we're usually 20 30
years older than me who around 45 had
kind of kind of lost their happiness and
now they were drinking a little too much
and their marriages weren't so good and
they didn't like the music so much and I
said I don't want to be those guys so I
got lucky that I saw it and I hatched a
plan I have to plan to escape and I
decided to go back to college
and I called my dad as a dad I got big
news I'm gonna quit music I'm gonna go
back to college
I'm gonna study I don't know literature
physics or poetry or economics or
something it's gonna be great I'm gonna
use my brain my dad said what are you
talking about said you've started a
family
you're doing fine it's very
irresponsible to just quit when you're
in your late 20s why I said dad because
I'm not happy and I don't think I'm
gonna be happy right and his long pause
and he says so what makes you so special
today I'm doing what I love today I'm
doing what I feel like I'm called to do
today my job is to talk to you about how
to have a happier life what a miracle
now it's not good enough for people to
accidentally find the way we need to
find it on purpose
okay so innate differences genetics 48
percent the next big one is big life
events this is what you think really
drives your happiness you want to be
happy go for your goals you've got these
big goals in your life and avoid the bad
stuff right you think about it all the
time if only I can graduate from college
with a good enough GPA and get a good
job then I'll be happy right if only get
into law school then I'll be happy if
only that girl will bury me
be happy and if I don't get sick I won't
be unhappy right if I don't have an
accident I won't be unhappy we think in
this way we're very goal-oriented
creatures now how much of our life
happened is that at any particular point
comes from the big things good and bad
answer is 40%
it's a lot it seems like you're
absolutely right to be chasing the big
thing at any particular moment trying to
avoid the big bad thing at any
particular moment but that's wrong it's
40% but I'm gonna tell you why not to
chase it two reasons number one is we're
very bad at getting the things that
we're seeking the big goals that we're
seeking but more importantly the big
things never last how long will your
mood be improve you get that dream house
six months but if I double your pay how
long will it improve your mood up to six
months no more no matter what you do
it's going to wear off the big stuff
wears off but the costs of doing these
big things lasts forever
don't chase the big thing there's one
study that really points this out it's
the most interesting study I've ever
seen
from 1978 actually it's an old study but
it's still classic and it compares two
groups of people quadriplegics and
people win the lottery okay now what do
these people have in common a huge
punctuation to their equilibrium boom
bad or good right now quadriplegics six
months after their accidents on average
their happiness has returned almost to
its level prior to their accident that's
what the studies show now not all the
way but almost all the way see what
durable we are six months later they
would they still say I would do almost
anything to get to be able to control my
arms and legs to not be confined to a
wheelchair but their happiness is
something that's innate and has to do
with other forces okay that's that's
finding number one number two is lottery
winners this one is actually even a
little bit more interesting six months
after you hit the lottery
the average lottery winner has permanent
baseline happiness levels that are
slightly below where they were the day
before they bought the ticket
literally the best thing that can happen
to you when you buy a lottery ticket is
that you don't win why we know this -
it's because they've blown their
circuits the little things in life don't
make them happy think about what's going
to make you happy this weekend hanging
out with loved ones it's doing the
things that give you a little bit of
gratification with the people who make
you happy you're gonna watch some sports
you you probably go out to dinner you're
going to be around people who you're
comfortable with you're going to joke
around have a great time turns out
people win the lottery don't get that
anymore all of their hobbies are draw
their friendships are all different they
don't enjoy the little things used to
enjoy before so they go in search of
more flavor the truth is if you want to
be happy don't spend your time obsessing
about the great big splash what you need
are habits that will give you the
highest likelihood of getting that 40%
that'll drive these events most likely
into your life and drive the bad things
out of your life in a regular framework
as a regular type of discipline so what
are these lifestyle elements and this
brings us to the last 12% remember 48
percent is genetics 40% is events you
got 12% left the 12% you have left are
under your control and if you do the
things you need to do to get the maximum
from the 12% you're also going to raise
this the likelihood of getting the 40%
because this gives you the best
lifestyle to give you the best luck so
what we need to know now are the things
and there are four of them that will
give you the 12% and this is where the
knowledge is power this is where you get
to walk out of here ready to invest in
your happiness portfolio and be a
happier person starting tonight here's
the good news
simple available to everybody and easy
to understand here the for faith family
community and work those are your big
four that's your happiness portfolio
don't waste your time on other stuff
because if you do you're gonna be going
in the wrong direction family I mean
sorry faith is it's pretty obvious the
interior life I'm not gonna tell you
which faith but thinking about the
transcendental
thinking about the things that are not
of this world and incorporating them
into your life family having solid
family relationships these are the
things that can't and shouldn't go away
community is a little bit more
complicated the elements of community
are cultivating important friendships
and being charitable in your community
being a charitable person toward others
that's what it means to have community
in your life now I'm going to spend my
time on faith family and community I'm
gonna spend the rest of my time on work
because that's the counterintuitive one
work is such a big deal you watch the
office you read Dilbert cartoons right
work is just a drag right at least for
other you probably like your job but
other people probably not so much what
percentage of Americans like or love
their jobs what percentage of Americans
are satisfied or very satisfied with
their work I think about it get a number
in your head you think in twenty twenty
five percent eighty nine percent eighty
nine percent of Americans are either
satisfied or very satisfied with their
jobs what an incredible thing if no
other country comes even remotely close
why why
let's cut money no that's not one of the
big four
I didn't say faith family community work
and money no money's not on the list and
in truth many economists including me
we've studied the effects of money on
happiness money does bring happiness by
relieving pressure to people who are
poor up to the level of the lower middle
class then it flattens out a lot brings
a little bit but it takes a lot of money
at higher income levels to bring any
sort of satisfaction
okay so money's really not it it's
something else what is it that brings so
much happiness of so many people from
work besides the guys were bummed out at
age forty five so what is it we've
looked we've looked we've looked and we
found it we found it it's earned success
it's the belief that you're creating
value with your life and value in the
lives of other people earned success is
truly the key to happiness through work
if you believe that you're serving
others and you're creating value with
everything that you do I don't care what
you do because people who believe that
they've earned their success and are
happy in their work
the same whether they have a college
degree or a high school degree or no
high school degree whether they have
above-average incomes or below average
income so they classify themselves as
lower middle class or a middle class or
upper middle class it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it matters whether or not
they think they are creating value with
their lives that they are earning their
success if you take two people precisely
the same their data from the University
of Chicago General Social Survey the
best survey database that we have in the
United States today
two people were the same age sex race
religion same level of education and
they both say that they have earned
their success but one person earns eight
times as much money as a second they
will be equally likely to say that they
are very happy about their lives what an
incredible thing money doesn't buy
happiness earned success is it and
that's what the guy on the motorcycle
has that's what he has he's earning his
success that's what we want I want to be
that guy why I want to have life on my
terms I want to build my life I want my
life to be my enterprise that's the
spirit of American entrepreneurship
that's the American dream our enterprise
is not building a business enterprise is
building your life and if you do it and
you earn your success then you pursue
your happiness that's the moral covenant
of our founders to us when they talked
about the fact that we're endowed by our
Creator with the unalienable rights of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness they might have said well have
said and earning our success what an
incredible miracle it's not just
happiness for you and me incidentally
happiness for everybody what's the
difference between now and the world I
grew up in when I was a little kid when
I was a little kid 1970 what was poverty
in the third world poverty in the third
world was a picture in the National
Geographic with a kid with a distended
belly and flies on his face who was poor
and was gonna die and there was nothing
I could do about it there was nothing
you could do about it that was poverty
in 1970 comparing 1972 today the
percentage of the world's population
living on a dollar a day or less this is
standard
measure of poverty among development
economists the percentage of the world's
population living on a dollar dere
lessons 1970 has declined by 80% that's
the world's greatest anti-poverty
achievement ever is it the fabulous
success of the United Nations is it it's
not a laugh line my friends is it the
International Monetary Fund of the World
Bank those might or might not be
effective organizations depending on
your point of view but it's not those
things it's five things according to
development economists it's
globalization free trade property rights
rule of law and entrepreneurship now you
can give to charity all night all day
long but you got to have a system that
works while you sleep you got to have a
system that works even when people are
not trying to make it work and that
system exists is the free enterprise
system what an incredible miracle the
Earned success system that brings you
happiness is the system of free
enterprise that lifts people out of
poverty that lets people live around the
world this is the reason that the free
enterprise system is not an economic
alternative as it's often described the
free enterprise system is a moral
imperative earned success needs the free
enterprise system poor people need the
free enterprise system
what is that system it's a system that
matches our skills with our passions
it's a system that celebrates hard work
and merit and personal responsibility
and rewards opportunity it's a system
where you can keep what you earn these
are moral goals because they lift people
up not because they make people rich
forget about making people rich they let
people live their life as an enterprise
that's what I accidentally found that's
the guy on the motorcycle that's what
people have a chance for the first time
in history to achieve in the third world
that's what you can build when you fight
for the free enterprise system I want
you to remember two things the pursuit
of happiness sounds complicated but it's
really not you have under your control
the portfolio to give you the most
happiness possible
start paying attention more more and
today to faith family community and work
second do you want the rest of the
country to be happier do you want the
rest of the world have a better shot at
the happiness that we feel is our moral
right passed on by our founders then
work for the system that makes it
possible don't work for the socialism
that makes it harder don't work for the
state ISM the collectivism that
suppresses this work for the free
enterprise that makes this possible
because if you do if you do that then
you're truly working for the common good
and for that my last words to you or
thank you